[Applaudissements]
rien pour l'instant ne dis rien par
exemple je ne veux pas savoir qui est
intéressé par Daniel
par contre toi tu la regardes en direct
tu as vu un arbre
on dirait que tu as vu un peu en direct
sur ma vie là
il vient de manger un morceau
tu croyais qu'il y avait une feuille à
l'intérieur
comment vous appelez Stéphane j'aime
bien Stéphane il a l'air de lui il est
bien hein Stéphane Stéphane c'est le
genre de mec qui peut non mais il peut
te vendre n'importe quoi
j'adore tu fais quoi dans la vie je suis
directeur d'école
tu vois tout de suite j'ai envie de lui
faire confiance je te jure c'est la voix
le truc le sourire lui même moi tu peux
me Ken
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment vous appelez
dans la vie moi je suis à Pôle Emploi
d'accord et puis je transporte des
enfants entre guillemets en difficulté
de l'école
alors les chéris on a deux personnes
il va lui faire des reflets au murdes
n'hésitez pas
on peut égaliser sur les côtés
les chéris alors je rappelle vos prénoms
et Didier Didier Stéphane et Didier
c'est qui là
c'est moi c'est horrible les gens qui
m'envoient des messages Stéphane et
Didier
il y en a un de vous deux
il y en a parfois
qui veulent gravir les vestes
qui va le faire Koh-Lanta
il y en a également
qui va gravir Daniel
pour cela il faut être bien équipé
j'espère que vous êtes passé au Vieux
Campeur avant
[Rires]
partir loin pour un voyage
dans une grotte
[Rires]
Daniel Moreau oui Les Chéries regardez
je peux la toucher les vivants
elle bouge encore ah oui oui et c'est
chaud là-dedans
le seul loup qu'elle a vu
c'est dans la forêt de simple barque en
Allemagne
dernière fois qu'elle l'a vu
Gilles Verdez
[Rires]
et aujourd'hui
ce qu'elle cherche Daniel
c'est certes une aventure mais surtout
de l'amour quelqu'un qui a envie de
s'investir quelqu'un qui a envie de
partir pour la grande aventure de
l'amour une autoroute sans péage où les
barrières se lèveront instantanément et
où vos barrières
à chaque appel de l'amour
les séries
il y en a un de vous deux
qui a envie de passer le cap avec qui
êtes-vous venu
un indice
s'affiche au bas de votre écran
Didier avec qui tu es venu tout seul
mais je suis marié
l'envie de tromper ta femme en direct
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Alex de Didier
il regarde l'ex-femme les papiers seront
envoyés demain par l'avocat
tu pouvais faire vite parce que là on
est sur un bail donc Didier ça n'est pas
toi c'est pas Didier Didier j'ai envie
quand même t'offrir un cadeau
mais franchement est-ce que j'ai envie
de t'offrir un weekend avec Nadia
allez vas-y tu veux partir j'ai envie de
je sais pas au Maroc Tunisie Los Angeles
[Applaudissements]
là tu peux m'attendre de petites
secondes
je peux pas faire tout et n'importe quoi
j'arrive pas à faire le Los Angeles mais
aux États-Unis ou peut-être dans un
autre pays
qui s'appelle le Los Angeles au Maroc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut offrir à l'idée
un vélo une très bonne nouvelle pour toi
[Applaudissements]
en France où tu veux thalasso truc
franchement c'est bien je suis en train
de voir si on peut essayer de faire
mieux d'accord
ça tombe elle a sur la tête de ma mère
moi j'ai l'impression d'être un aéroport
on me dit des destinations toutes les
secondes il y a 2 secondes il était à
Dieppe après l'état Marseille
tu es à New York
[Applaudissements]
tu te rends compte que si tu avais eu
plus de cheveux tu restais ici parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vais je vais d'abord vérifier si on a
assez d'argent
puis Stéphane et la personne le revenant
Stéphane
tu es directeur d'école tu es magnifique
franchement tu es très très bel homme
vraiment merci je te le dis c'est
vraiment
elle adore les corbeilles
[Rires]
je vais te poser la question fatidique
cette question vous la connais tous ici
mais avant de te poser la question
petite interview de musique
c'est parti Michel Fugain c'est un bon
roman c'est une belle histoire
[Applaudissements]
t'inquiète pas c'est pour toi et tu nous
diras dans un instant si tu es le rose
élu juste avant
si vous voulez nous rejoindre
[Rires]
de savoir si Stéphane est la bonne
personne avant notre interlude musicale
est-ce que il te plaît
si j'ai vendu un petit peu la mèche
c'est pas sans raison
la musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un beau roman c'est une belle
histoire
c'est une romance d'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
il rentrait chez lui
là dans le brouillard
elle descendait dans le midi le midi
il se serait retrouvé
au bord du chemin
sur l'autoroute des vacances
c'était sans doute un jour de chance
la porte de la main
un cadeau de la Providence alors de quoi
penser au lendemain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils se sont cachés
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vous ai vu tous les deux
et franchement vous faites un couple
magnifique
je vais mettre là-bas pour mieux juger
et je vais vous recommander
plusieurs distances
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si tous à mes cheveux il est morte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes réunis
par la force du destin
Daniel comment as-tu eu l'info que
Stéphane avait
un petit bail pour toi alors nous avons
un excellent chauffeur de salle qui ne
chauffe pas que là
et c'est lui qui m'a dévoilé un petit ce
petit secret
et j'ai voilà j'ai eu envie de me mais
tu l'avais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les élèves se disent demain on va avoir
une nouvelle directrice
[Applaudissements]
Stéphane la question que tout le monde
se pose
c'est est-ce que c'est ton corps des
fausses rumeurs
et putaclic
ils nous ont envoyé vers cette fausse
information ou bien est-ce que Stéphane
tu as vraiment un Crush
pour Daniel
est-ce que Stéphane tu es séduit en plus
aujourd'hui je te trouve magnifique
tu es sur rigoler je te le dis je te dis
tu es superbe arrête un peu arrête votre
mari
aime bien mais ma mère aimerait bien que
tu pécho c'est bon à chaque fois lui
présente au moins de 6e mec alors je
vous dis la vérité pour moi jamais eu au
niveau là
je vais vous dire la vérité là
c'est une chance ça ça tombe une fois
c'est comme si qu'elle avait gagné à
l'Euro Millions
c'est la même c'est la même
dans sa culotte
[Applaudissements]
Stéphane un peu de poésie oui il est
romantique
la vérité laissez-moi vous marier
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait les plus grandes marmites
sur la chaise frère je l'ai fait je l'ai
régalé vous feriez l'animation bien sûr
Stéphane est-ce que cette rumeur est
vrai oui elle est partie vrai
monde juste un truc Stéphane ne joue pas
avec elle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu ne joues pas avec les sentiments
bravo Daniel franchement tu sais que
même moi sur la tête d'un chat je
regrette de ne pas avoir de Shrek
[Rires]
en
dis-moi la vérité
est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce que tu étais déboussolé
je suis troublée mais c'est vrai que
c'est presque trop beau en fait pour
vas-y lâche-toi là n'est jamais trop
beau Stéphane est-ce que je peux j'ai
dit envie de dire forcer un petit peu le
destin est-ce que vous êtes est-ce que
tu es libre cette semaine peut-être pour
aller mieux vous connaître peut-être
aller déjeuner d'abord déjeuner
[Rires]
un repas du soir c'est plus agréable
mais malheureusement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le soir elle s'occupe de t'occupes de ta
maman oui est-ce que si sur la tête de
ma mère tu sais que je suis capable de
le faire pour toi je ne rigole pas je
m'occupe je vais chez toi je m'occupe de
ta mère
vous adore sur ma vie j'y vais avec
Raymond c'est mon pote
mais je veux toujours
faire la même chose je vais regarder
crime et puis voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je la connais il a des pieds de chats
je me retourne il mange un sandwich hier
alors ma chérie non mais est-ce que je
sais que vous pourrez le faire à un
moment
tu pourrais gagner
et ce soir ce soir tu peux ça
il faut battre il faut battre le faire
quand il est chaud et là je suis né
à côté frère
attendez
ok
est-ce que tu peux regarder pendant que
je m'occupe de l'autre de la coiffure va
voir tout de suite si toi c'est bon le
prends ton tel tu vas appeler la date à
domicile tu regardes ça toi
on y est pas j'adore frère mais tu veux
que je te dis super ouais mais c'est pas
ça que je veux je veux je veux qu'on se
dise on le voit je veux que les
téléspectateurs se disent mais c'est pas
gilbertez
[Rires]
non mais moi moi je demande le
spécialiste est-ce que toi toi tu es
vraiment envisagé
[Rires]
un petit peu de longueur sur le dessus
Adrien avec un peu plus de barbe tu vois
pour que ça aille comme ça en avant et
la nuit plus courte
un peu plus courtes
et on va tu sais quoi j'adore ah bah
c'est bien
magnifique il faut plus qu'on voit tes
yeux est-ce que j'aurais fait moi
j'aurais raté intégralement les sourcils
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est fini quoi
normalement elle regarde l'émission
Daniel votre maman et moi on vous
regarde non
[Applaudissements]